[Music]
this is star talk i'm your host your
personal astrophysicist neil degrasse
tyson and i got with me today matt
kirschen matt welcome back dude thanks
neil how you doing doing good good and
you are host of your own podcast called
probably science and i finally got that
right
nailed it nailed it this time
yeah i spent i think i spent 10 episodes
saying is it could be science might have
thought it could have been science and
so i'm still waiting for answer to any
of those i'm still waiting for my next
invitation because i enjoyed my the my
one time appeared
at any time that i i just i i never want
to abuse my connection to you but the
second you have a book to plug a reason
to be doing the rounds of interviews we
are jumping on that all right excellent
excellent so the topic of today is the
james webb space telescope which is in
all the news because it's been planned
it's been
talked about for up to two decades now i
remember it was in some of our proposals
in my astrophysics communities we said
you know we could use an infrared
telescope
tuned to see the edge of the universe
and that same infrared would enable us
to find planets you know
i remembered thinking that through with
my community and now it's real
it's a real thing so turns out we have
two guests for this episode of star talk
first is nathaniel kahn who is the
director of a newly released documentary
on i think it'll be appearing on cnn
he'll tell us where it's all about the
making of the james webb space telescope
and he follows the scientists and the
engineers and just you you end up
getting in the middle of it also we're
going to talk to him in the first
segment and then after that we're going
to bring on one of the scientists who's
looking for exoplanets to try to maybe
replace earth maybe they know something
we don't
can we hit your ride with them so let me
let me first get on here nathaniel kahn
nathaniel welcome to star talk thank you
it's a great pleasure to be here yeah
today's topic is we're going to talk
about the james webb space telescope
this has been in the news for a decade
and more
we proposed this even longer ago than
that
and in the astrophysics community uh
it's a telescope that's very
specifically tuned
for very specific tasks but before we
get into that let me introduce nathaniel
nathaniel you
produced a movie
a movie a film excuse me film that's
what you guys call it
yes he's british to talk a talkie it's a
talkie exactly exactly we're off to a
good start here yeah
on the making of
the james webb space telescope and it's
called the hunt for planet b
and so
you're you're the director of this film
and i'm flattered to report here that
your team asked me to be interviewed for
it but i was swamped at the time that
request came in so you managed to make
it without me that's
it was difficult i'll tell you it was it
was difficult no we really wanted you
he's come here now we're here now
talking about it so one of the
scientists who features was natalie
batala who in fact we will bring on to
star talk in segments two and three but
right now uh we want to find out what
was your thinking behind making this
documentary
well i mean this is the biggest
mission biggest pure science mission
that nasa has ever undertaken and it's
an international effort it's it's uh the
canadian space agency the european space
agency and nasa working together to
build this incredible telescope which
you described
the web space telescope and it's been
you know two decades in the making it's
10 000 people have worked on it one time
or another if you do the math it's like
it's it's you know thousands of human
years have gone into building this thing
um it is a telescope that uh
the largest space telescope ever
undertaken um and the biggest science
mission nasa has ever done so for a
documentary filmmaker it's thrilling to
be able to watch this thing come
together i mean it's like it's like
watching a cathedral being built or
something like that wow so cosmic
cathedral if you want to obliterate that
a cosmic cathedral exactly a cathedral
that's really hard to repair if
something is wrong
that's the thing i mean the stakes the
stakes the stakes of this thing talk
about also for matt don't ruin his
delivery
just ruined everything you're not doing
anything about delivery
you're putting the ball right on the tee
the stakes for this thing could not be
higher we all know about hubble right
that when hubble went up
um in 19 what was it neil was it 1990 90
91 around there
yeah um when it went up you know there
was a problem and remember i don't know
if you remember but hubble didn't focus
you know the the star images were blurry
and it was you know it was considered it
for a moment it was people were calling
it a techno turkey and you know
this is a big waste of money you know
but luckily astronauts could go up and
fix it it's only 250 miles over our
heads but the webb space telescope is
going to be a million miles from earth
it's in this this orbit called l2 out
you know four times further than the
moon it is not fixable it has to work
first time
only time we've got one swing at this
thing and it's got to go out of the park
so the stakes of this telescope are as
high as they can be so
i got to correct something you said you
said that luckily astronauts could fix
it it was designed to be fixed so yeah
to be deployed by the shuttle then
astronauts could return in the shuttle
so it wasn't so much luck as planning
but no one planned to have to fix it
from from jump street right so right
right yeah that's right
right yeah um that's going to be the
most i i've spoken to a few um
rocket scientists nasa scientists both
you know through
through my association with this show
and through other means and i can't
imagine anything more
stressful than you know i i wrote joking
and then i'll send them to uh to i'll
file my script and then i'll send them
to the studio floor and then the person
will deliver them and the audience may
or may not laugh and if they don't laugh
i'm like i screwed up today but there's
another day i don't have to
watch that joke orbiting the earth for
the rest of my life
failing every time one shot to tell the
joke and it has to be not only the
perfect joke but the delivery has to be
perfect oh and that joke cost society
millions and millions of dollars yeah
billions billions
billions billions off by factors of
thousands but uh just a quick a quick
back story here the james webb space
telescope is
especially tuned to observe infrared
light
at
an infrared wavelength that
forming galaxies in the beginning of the
universe which at that time are emitting
ultraviolet light
over the lifetime of the universe the
ultraviolet red shifts through the
entire visible spectrum and lands in the
infrared
so this telescope was tuned to see the
birth of galaxies in the universe after
they had redshifted
for 14 billion years it turns out
infrared is really good for probing deep
gas clouds
and seeing what's going on there and
nathaniel tell us what's going on in the
in the in the wombs of gas clouds in our
galaxy
well i mean that's that's uh that's one
of the great things this telescope can
do as you say it can peer through these
these uh clouds of dust and gas that we
could never see through before and
actually see planets being formed so
this is something we really haven't seen
very much before a little bit we have
because there's been some infrared
astronomy before of course very good
stuff but this telescope is exquisitely
sensitive larger more it's a hundred
times more powerful than hubble and able
to see into these cocoons these sort of
you know pillars of creation as they're
called where planets are actually
coalescing and we're seeing the
beginnings of what we have now in this
solar system 4.5 billion years after our
solar system began so we're seeing the
very beginnings of as you said neil
really the beginnings of of the universe
we're looking back towards the very
first stars the very first galaxies 13.5
billion years ago when the first we've
never seen these stars before never seen
the first stars never seen the first
galaxies and also never really seen into
these dust clouds where new planets are
being formed and also there's this kind
of other other ability the telescope has
which is really a lot of the focus of
the film the hunt for planet b which is
there are these uh exoplanets which are
planets around other stars other than
our sun
and
25 years ago we didn't really know that
these existed as neil as you said we
surmised that they did but they we
didn't know that they were there now we
know that virtually every star in the
sky has at least one planet around it
which is astonishing i mean think about
it go out at the night sky and look up
and you see that every star in the sky
has at least one planet around it and
some of them have multiple planets this
telescope is able to look at
some of those planets and actually look
in the atmospheres of some of those
planets and see if there might be
elements
that might
indicate the possibility
of life on those other worlds so this is
like this is this is a game changer
moment a game changer instrument
and it's about to launch you know just a
couple weeks from now so what i like
about it is it's it's
it's taking us to the nearest objects in
the universe
which could be other planets that
resemble earth and the farthest objects
in the universe it's people
normally don't think of telescopes as
having that kind of highly different
dual capability but jwst
is that i was going to realize where it
launches from because i actually
i got to see my first
rocket launch recently
there was a
you know most of them go from the
east coast from florida but i got to see
one of the ones that goes from just up
the coast in california
uh it was the uh
the the armageddon mission the the
mission that's going to be hit knocking
uh
an asteroid and they launched from just
up the road near santa barbara so went i
was like why haven't i ever gone to one
of these so we just we gave these
permissions it was amazing who gave you
permission to call the armageddon
mission who gave you permission
yeah yeah the darts
it's the anti-armageddon
deflect the asteroid yeah so where is
this getting launched nathaniel so this
is so this is getting i mean get this we
don't actually currently have a rocket
right in the united states big enough to
launch this
telescope we need to go to
the ariane 5 rocket which is the
european space agency arianespas makes
it and it's going it's going to launch
from french guyana so it's going down to
a place called kuru
and there's a spaceport down there and
they have this special fairing that
they've built which allows which is the
part that actually encloses the
telescope this telescope is so big they
actually have to fold it up to fit into
the rocket it's like it's a transformer
telescope it's an interstellar butterfly
if you will it has a sun shield on it
that's the size of a tennis court that
could never fit in a rocket fully
deployed so all this stuff folds up into
a cocoon and it launches out a million
miles from earth on this rocket leaving
from kuru uh french guyana and um it's
it's an awesome sight
in your film how would you describe the
balance of attention you gave to the
science that we seek and the engineering
marvels that it required
well that's i mean it's a fantastic
question and i wanted to balance them
both because too often the engineering
doesn't get enough credit you know all
the glory goes to scientists this you
know no no engineering no science so the
whole idea was to be able to follow this
thing coming together the technical
challenges i mean there were there were
at least a dozen new technologies that
had to be invented just to make this
telescope so creating it building it and
it's a one-off i mean it's never been
done before so all the challenges of
solving these engineering problems how
do you make a telescope that folds up
how do you make this telescope that has
a mirror that's that is uh it's 21 feet
across so this thing has to open up
hubble's mirror is you know is only two
and a half meters across so this is
where this is this is six and a half
meters across much much bigger so how do
you solve all those challenges and it's
made of multiple mirrors that all at the
focused at one point incredibly complex
engineering problems so following those
problems as well as the aspirations of
the scientists so the dreams of the
scientists the scientists can't wait for
this thing to get on orbit they've been
waiting for a couple of decades for it
so this kind of wonderful dialogue
between the engineering making this
thing the scientists waiting for this
thing the dreams of humanity being
launched out there four times further
than the moon uh that's sort of that's
the focus of the film um so it's this
it's this combination
so it's one thing for a documentarian to
come on the scene when everything's
ready to go and interview people but you
actually shadowed exactly scientists for
about how long did you do this
well i was lucky enough to be able to
document the you know the process the
telescope was delayed a number of times
for really for obvious reasons which is
you know as you're doing something new
that's never been done before you
encounter problems and the last thing
you want is to launch something that
isn't you know that isn't perfect so
i've been shadowing this for about five
years now which you know pales in
comparison to some of these scientists
and some of these engineers have been
working on it for two decades for their
career this whole career yeah it's it's
a whole career that's exactly right and
one of the things that i i found so sort
of moving about it was you know there
we have so many challenges and so many
problems in the world today
but to see
the hopefulness
of the scientists and the engineers
working on this thing
the
the willingness as you said neil the
willingness to put your whole career on
the line and and and for something with
an unknown outcome we don't we you know
we hope it's going to work we've made
every single you know taken every single
contingency into account we hope it's
going to find amazing things i'm sure it
will i have great confidence knowing the
people that it will but there it takes a
lot of
a lot of faith really
um for the engineers and the scientists
to put this much of their life into
something faith belief
love for passion for what they're doing
passionately to be able to document that
and to see it to see that passion and to
experience it was you know one of the
great sort of joys of my filmmaking
career
so matt you don't put this much effort
into a joke i guess
yeah no i've been working on the same
joke since uh since uh birth and i've
got a team of thousands of material come
on
yeah we've got some good international
funding and you gotta fold it up to take
it into the club
and and they don't really fit into the
fairing so i'm sure the metaphor there
but yes yes right i i do have one
question one question and without sort
of spoiling the film um but i know like
whenever anyone makes a documentary they
always set off with a film in mind but
then it changes as
as you start filming and discovering so
what so what was the biggest sort of
discovery or or change in your mission
as a filmmaker from the
from what you set off to do and what you
discovered in the process
um no that's that's that's absolutely
you're absolutely right and and the
really the sort of great thing about
take a making a film that that that
takes five years is that things happen
that change your focus and your focus
begins to sort of
you know find it you begin to find the
film begins to find itself as you go
along and the way that i like to make
films i don't like to go in knowing
exactly what i'm going to do because
then you're just kind of you know you're
you're you're telling a story that
already exists you want one of the great
things about documentaries is you don't
know where it's going to go so in this
case
um it started out being fully about the
building of the telescope and as it went
along it it really this this field of
exoplanets became stronger and stronger
so i was able to then meet a lot of
scientists and many of them are women
which is a very strong aspect of the of
the story which is that uh you know for
years
much of science has been dominated by
you know
it's dominated by this by the same old
group that we always see right but but
um exoplanets were sort of a a uh an
area of science that was not as sort of
not as it was almost considered fringy
so a lot of people got into it who kind
of couldn't advance in other areas and
so there were many people who flooded
into that field young people um people
who weren't able to advance in other
areas and suddenly this field takes off
so i was able to document this kind of
almost seismic shift
in the world of astrophysics in which we
have these teams of people now doing
great science and many of them are led
by
some of these
amazing women who were in the film
so being able to document that kind of
seismic shift
was
terrific that was one thing that that
happened and the other thing was that at
the same time we were making the film
um the climate marches were happening
and young people around the world were
talking about about climate change and
saying look there is no planet b we only
have this earth we have to take care of
it so suddenly wow there was the title
right there that well the reality is out
there
you know there are probably planet bees
we're we're on the verge of finding
these things out however however
we're a long way from being able to go
to any planet bees we have to take care
of planet a we have to take care of this
planet so the kind of the the
interchange between the search for for
other worlds
allowing us to see our own world with
fresh eyes became a focus for the film
that i can't say i started you know i
started out thinking that way it started
out being documenting this amazing
telescope and it blossomed into this
much much larger story okay just admit
it you had a kumbaya moment in the movie
just just i didn't just admit it
no it's like as a filmmaker you're like
yes we finally you know got something
really great here something that's gonna
that's gonna mesh with some you know you
always look for something which takes
you deeper and as you say it is the
kumbaya moment you know for for a
filmmaker where you realize okay wait a
minute this story that i'm telling
suddenly has resonances that i didn't
anticipate the cultural resonance
telling yeah yes and
actually you know cosmic cosmic
resonances right um global resonances i
mean these are you know um these these
are things we we have to contend with
and if a telescope like this
gets us to think about ourselves as a
global community and that's that's part
of this aspect of documenting the teams
and the teams that built that built the
telescope you see the ability to solve
nearly impossible problems plus they're
really complicated together they're real
people doing it real people doing it and
it's yours it's your duty yes an
obligation as a documentarian to capture
that fact so when i watch it i can feel
what they're feeling and they become
real to me not just real in their own
world there there's there's even a love
story in the film so yeah so it's uh
it's it's
is it between james white have been
hubble
uh
no i hadn't thought of that one thing no
no that's not no that's that's the next
piece that's the next one yeah
yeah all the space telescopes have a
jamboree and there's like love affair
no these telescopes want to stay far
apart they don't want to interfere with
each other so so where can we find where
can we find it who's
who's got it cnn has it um and see cnn
cnn did a a broadcast
of it
just last week and um it will be it will
be available continue to be available
okay so see we'll land on cnn plus
because they have a new streaming
platform uh that's my guess yes it will
yeah yeah okay absolutely it will it
will indeed so we can find it okay
nathaniel we're going to send you away
um that means we don't love talking to
you but we got to make room
uh absolutely when stark talk returns
we're going to feature one of the
scientists who was featured in your film
to talk about uh her research and what
it means for her to search for planet b
when star talk returns
we're back
star talk segment two all about the
james webb space telescope
and we thought uh following on the heels
of our
our documentarian
he featured
several scientists but one in particular
we managed to bring onto star talk and
that happens to be
natalie batala did i pronounce that
right
natalie that was really good yes vitalia
oh battalia okay thank you thank you oh
yeah no you you got it i've heard all
kinds of variations you did
excellent excellent so so you're one of
the uh lead scientists uh in thinking
about planets and planet hunting with
the james webb space telescope
but we you're tracking your professional
tracking having read your a bit of your
bio took you through the kepler
telescope so just remind us what kepler
is and why do you care about other
planets
so kepler was a space telescope too it
was a one meter telescope in space
orbiting the sun
and its objective was to find
potentially habitable terrestrial-sized
planets
and it did that in spades it found over
four thousand planets um many hundreds
of which are the size of earth and some
fraction of those are even potentially
habitable or in the in the goldilocks
zone
so with the kepler data we were able to
do
demographic studies to understand the
diversity of planets to understand how
common they are in the galaxy to
understand how many potential abodes of
life there might be all right so that's
kepler so then
why do we need
jwst to look for planets if kepler's
sound like yeah well
with most of the discovery techniques
all of the discovery techniques so far
what can we measure we can measure bulk
properties the total mass the radius the
orbital period which via kepler's laws
tells us the distance between the planet
and the star so you know how much
radiation it's receiving if you know how
hot the central star is
very basic properties and one of the
takeaways from kepler
is that the diversity of planets in the
galaxy far exceeds the diversity of
planets in our own solar system there's
all kinds of crazy worlds out there and
we want to understand that diversity
because there will be implications for
habitability and where these most likely
abodes of life will be
so webb gives us this new lens on
exoplanet diversity instead of just
measuring the bulk
will actually be dissecting the
atmosphere and understanding what
molecules are in the atmosphere and
that's going to give us insights into
many of the details about that planet's
history and nature
so matt you heard she's on a one-name
basis with the telescope you heard her
say that well webb will yeah
webster to his friends
yeah well i'm not there yet maybe i'm
not i'm not familiar enough but you're
calling awst or what are you calling i
don't know i i i will follow your lead
i'll follow your lead so uh j-dog
the generations tell us that's what
we've been calling in
so natalie you're professor of astronomy
at uc santa cruz i visited that campus
just once and it was it wasn't real it
was like a movie set i don't think it's
really exist
my office is like living in a treehouse
do you see the redwoods outside my
window there
feels like i'm living in a dream house
and let's see if my co-host knows
what the mascot is of uc santa cruz
i i do i got a friend who went there
it's the banana slice the bananas yeah
very cool and weird well done
[Laughter]
so natalie i don't know if you knew but
this is actually a cosmic queries
segment and we solicited questions from
our patreon members and because they
just have exclusive access to our guests
through this medium of questions and
answers and so matt has collected them
and so so matt i have yeah so these are
questions just you know what this
generally about the telescope about the
search for planets oh wait before just
before we go there matt let me just ask
natalie this documentary
is titled planet
b
where we spent the first segment
speaking with its director
are you planning something that we don't
know about are you
are you
is there some escape
that
ship
that you let us in on
what's going on there's only enough room
for me and my family sorry
no i actually it's no secret i told
nathaniel that i didn't care for that
title uh the reason i didn't care for it
is because it kind of reverts back to
this colonial language i'm trying to get
away from
so i'm not finding other planets as a
backup plan for planet earth when it is
destroyed i care a lot about planet
earth and if anything it's just the
opposite the more you look for planets
elsewhere the more you love your home
and the more you realize how precious it
is
but looking for these planets that could
host life teaches us something about the
extremes of habitability and and
eventually about the sustainability of
life here on planet earth so nathaniel i
think did a really great job of of
communicating that point through the
film
so that made up for the title and in all
fairness the full title is the hunt for
planet b not let's secretly go to planet
b after we find it so i just want to run
it with our
with our nets and our bows and arrows
yeah
stitch a trailer to the back of the
rocket you can do that right that
doesn't affect how things fly
so matt what do you have for her you can
water ski i have so many questions so
i'm going to try and get through as many
as we can let's do it your patreon
patrons have gone all out on this topic
it is a big one so let's start with um
jeff johnson asks i i think this is
quite probably a size up even from this
massive telescope but jeff wants to know
how big would a telescope have to be to
see features like cities on planets in
other solar systems such a good great
question
uh all of the detection techniques we
have so far and now even the
characterization techniques
they're unable to resolve the surfaces
of planets we don't even see them as a
circle it's just a point of light in the
best case scenario you collect that
light maybe spread it out into a rainbow
and you look for all of these chemical
fingerprints that are in the light
but that doesn't mean that we haven't
thought about what such a future looks
like
what technology would enable
resolving the surfaces of planets and
what we've come up with so far maybe the
future will hold surprises but so far
we're thinking about a a
network of what's called interferometers
in space
well separated out kind of like the alma
array of uh sub-millimeter telescopes in
the desert they work in concert they
combine their light make use of the fact
that you can spread them out over great
distances which gives you very sharp
spatial resolution so maybe that's
something that we'll do in the future
what's behind that is of course the
bigger the telescope the more resolution
you have so if you have multiple
telescopes scattered across the
landscape they have an effective size
that is the distance between them right
it's not just one single
lens and so that's that's what natalie's
talking about there and so yeah i look
forward to that but let me let me invert
the question and ask
how far away
can you still know that earth has cities
given telescopes that we have so where
would you have to put jwst where it
could see the cities of earth
how about that
so they say webb can detect a bumblebee
on the moon
bumblebee smaller than a city right
so how much smaller what factor yeah so
like a thousand times further away than
the moon so let's say at the edge of the
solar system yeah okay cool well no it
could it should be able to detect if a
city is a million times bigger than a
bumblebee
it should be able to
be put a million times farther away and
see a city yeah exactly yeah yeah i'm
still guessing that's not going to get
us to the nearest star no
but it get us to the edge of the solar
system turn around with a telescope like
web and look at the earth from the edge
of the solar system
you you'd probably be able to see city
lights okay all right cool actually dan
dymac uh asked a question similar to
that which is like is there a reason we
send singular telescopes rather multiple
smaller ones
and
uh he says i get that increases
complexity but if the singular jwst
fails that's it rather an array of
smaller telescopes which don't just stop
working if one fails so why aren't we
sending lots of smaller telescopes up
rather than this one massive one what
advantage do we get from this big one
there are multiple advantages i mean
what do telescopes do
first and foremost they are light
collecting buckets so they help us to
see further and fainter than we've ever
seen before just because they collect
more photons so you want big light
buckets
this idea of combining light of multiple
telescopes which is the subject of
interferometry which we were talking
about before would be fantastic let's do
that the technical challenge though is
that those telescopes have to be held in
a very precise formation pattern they
have to be at
such precise distances from one another
that the the precision is comparable to
the wavelength of light itself which is
like a millionth of a meter or even a
trillionth of a meter so that is
technically challenging we don't know
how to do that with very high precision
at least in the optical right now from
space
right so that would be even more
expensive
um so if we want to study exoplanets and
we want to look back to the first 100
million years of the galaxy when the
very first galaxy's formed we need a
very big light bucket and that's what
web is
all right
it's cool so it's all about buckets it's
a bucket thing
yeah so i i love that yeah this
incredibly complicated piece of
equipment that's classic and she's
calling it a bucket so wait wait then we
get to call it our bucket list ah i see
what i did there
we go
well along those lines what
what is the first priority what is
priority one for the james webb
telescope once it's in position and
what's the first thing either of you
would like to see and that question
comes from kevin the sommelier and i
want to know back at kevin um what is
the best wine to pair with space
we know space has a smell i've heard
that on a previous episode of this show
uh all right let's see
high on my priority list um
well i have a bias because i study
exoplanets and i have so many burning
questions that i want answered so i
really want to look at those first
but the other
physics in our astrophysics that we're
doing is super cool
for instance they say that we can detect
traces of the very first supernovae that
went off in the universe
that sounds amazing to be able to see
the very first galaxies kind of the
moment when the lights in the universe
flicked on that's tremendously exciting
to see the nearest galaxies in high
resolutions to the point where you can
make out individual stars and watch them
being born in real time
on a kind of a galactic scale is very
exciting
we have these images from the alma array
which i mentioned earlier which is this
array of sub-millimeter telescopes in
the atacama desert who are combining
light to observe
proto-planetary disks where baby planets
are being formed today
we see the material they end up looking
like these complex disks of material
that have structure like thin rings or
spiral structure and the current
thinking is all of that structure is
caused by the baby planets that are
embedded in that dust and gas
with webb we will be able to find the
planets themselves and make sure and
verify that that theory that's what's
creating this structure is due to
planets
so that's all the other stuff but what
i'm really excited about is to observe
exoplanets in order to resolve some
long-standing
mysteries
for example
one of the most common actually the most
common type of planet that kepler
identified and it appears it's one of
the most common types of planets in the
galaxy is a kind of planet we don't even
have in our solar system
we don't understand their nature we
don't understand if this is more real
estate for life or if it's something
completely exotic and different maybe
it's an ocean world a planet like earth
it's completely enveloped in an ocean we
don't know so i'm very excited to
observe those planets and figure that
out
um there's one planetary system called
trappist 1 that has
seven terrestrial-sized planets orbiting
it three of which are in the goldilocks
zone and webb has the capability of
being able to detect their atmospheres
that's another observation that's going
to be done right away
so i'm i'm very excited to see what
comes out of that all right matt give me
some more um
okay well daniel scary wants to know
with a myriad of systems eh which must
pull up perfectly how confident or
worried or worried are astronomers that
james webb will deploy successfully
actually before we commit natalie to
get to get her vote of confidence or not
in the telescope let's take a break and
we will find out from natalie
how reliable is the engineering
on the james red space telescope when
star talk returns
we're back star talk
cosmic query segment
of our attention given to the james webb
space telescope and we have one of the
uh investigators of the science
of this telescope who focuses on
exoplanets and that's natalie batala
battalia but
help me again you got it right the
second time
you're doing great patala natalie batali
yes yes
uh and uh it's been great just hearing
you just wax poetic about
what this telescope will do for for us
and there's so many hopes pinned on it
people's entire career
who
engineers and scientists who it's been
taken that long to develop the telescope
to conceive it develop it build it and
now to launch it wait for it to get out
there and then have it unfurl matt that
question bring it to me again
yeah how confident are we that it's
gonna it's gonna do its thing but it's
going to get up there because we already
established in the first segment
with nathaniel that there is no
there's no redos on this one there's no
sending astronauts up to fix this guy
is that going to stop us
no
we're going to dare mighty things and
we're going to do it anyway and i don't
find that worry is a particularly useful
emotion
it is what it is
and we do our best
and we make use of the what is it like a
dollar 33 per tax payer per year for 20
years cost
i i know that's not trivial and um i'm
not making light of it
uh but this idea that it will destroy
our careers i think is not the case if
web if something god forbid goes wrong
then we'll pick up the pieces we'll go
back to the drawing board and do what
scientists do so well which is problem
solve natalie we wanted you to weep or
something all right not just say
everything yeah
[Music]
oh my god
i'm so nervous
[Laughter]
no yeah i mean
and i'm saying that from the perspective
of i mean it's my career that's on the
line as well in addition to my daughter
so i feel it very viscerally um but
there's a lot of archival data there are
other things that we will do and and we
will go back to the drawing board figure
out what happened and we'll do it better
next time the reality is that we want
lots of telescopes out at l2 in the
future we want to be able to build them
there to service them there eventually
it's a great place to put telescopes and
in order to learn how to do that we got
to keep trying sometimes fail and
hopefully
most of the time succeed natalie that is
so
level-headed and rational a response to
that question and we were just
hoping and expecting that you just be
weeping
this is what's supposed to happen people
spend decades of their life and they're
just and and you're just well that's how
that cookie crumbles and so i don't know
what's wrong what's which is better i
don't know i like it though because it's
all data
whatever happens you've got data and
you'll work out how to damn that we all
sensible about it we have to be like a
spacex and you know just kind of have a
more of a mentality that failure is a
part of it you know i think that we
progress faster when we allow for
failure this would be a tremendous
setback don't get me wrong and and it's
a very expensive one so um but nasa does
this well and i i have a lot of
confidence in the engineers
and just to emphasize what you just said
uh order to highlight i think people
don't fully understand or embrace the
meaning of failure
on the frontier of discovery
and they think everything's got to work
perfectly well if everything worked
perfectly
then you're not actually on the frontier
because that meant you made no mistakes
at all yeah it's an impossible standard
right and that only nasa's
yeah
and
finally so because it's tax payer
dollars but um
but they're if you you can't have it
both ways you can't push the frontier
and never make a mistake those two
things
are not synonymous that advice was given
to me in my career by a martin
schwartzchild who is a relative of the
original carl swartzchild of the
schwarzschild radius of black holes
he was a professor at princeton when i
was there and he
he said the day you stop making mistakes
that's the day you know you were no
longer on the frontier
and i put it all
in context but anyhow matt give me some
more and we'll try we this is our last
segment how many we can put in and
natalie let's see if we can go to
lightning mode
well luckily we we've covered quite a
few things just in the course of
answering quick people's questions just
over the course of natalie talking but
dylan wants to know and dylan's a high
school senior so i like the questions
from younger people wants to know what
the telescope can do hopes to do that
hubble can't or isn't good at doing and
what discoveries do you hope to make
that i might see dylan says as i work my
way through college and this interests
me as well because we were talking in
the first segment about how natalie your
entire field has gone in the course of
the last decade even
even half of your not even half of your
career has gone from being this sort of
tiny sliver of astrophysics to this
massive world as
we've gone from maybe there being an
exoplanet to being
every star yeah that's right i mean in
my career i wasn't even an exoplanet
scientist when i got my phd i was
studying stellar astrophysics exoplanets
didn't exist until until the latter half
of my grad career so um things are
changing tremendously what white meat
what might we see that hubble couldn't
see
well first of all we're looking at a
completely different color space we're
going over to the infrared um where dust
will glow and allow us to probe disk
chemistry or star formation the
chemistry of star-forming clouds we have
a big enough light bucket to see the
atmospheres of planets smaller than the
giant planets planets like these weird
mysterious super earths or sub neptune
type planets even planets as small as a
terrestrial size planet that's never
been done before we will have also a big
enough light bucket to look all the way
back to the very first galaxies forming
in the universe
from that we will be able to create a
flip book of galaxy evolution from the
start to the modern age of the universe
so all of these are are new things that
have never been done before and what you
should expect to hear about over the
next 10 years
well wait natalie he's in high school
you can't use the phrase flip book okay
you say
we're going to make a movie of the
evolution of galaxies
not the same
cartoon oh my gosh
who knows what a flip book is anymore
before before talkies and before movies
you'd flip the images and they would
move they'll just know it as like you
you look through the slits in the
cylinder as you rotate but you turn the
handle
um well well quentin from switzerland
asks and you've asked do you expect to
see different chemical compounds in the
atmosphere of exoplanets which you've
already answered and says
but then says for you personally what
would be the most surprising or exciting
thing for it to detect the thing i don't
know about every time we put a new piece
of technology into space
we lift the veil to some new reality
that we couldn't have imagined before
though with kepler it was this serious
name i get that i get that but
but
you have now access to the chemistry of
an exoplanet atmosphere
what molecule will excite you most in
your molecule list
i think nasa has a pr problem because
we're going to be studying
carbon dioxide methane
you know
just the the kind of the typical
greenhouse gases and we're going to be
doing it not in this beautiful color
space that people are used to with
hubble but we're going to be looking at
rain be looking at rainbows we're going
to be looking at a bunch of squiggly
lines and when i see
carbon dioxide you know with hubble we
see
water features in giant planets
and we
model that to imagine what the abundance
of carbon dioxide might be
because we don't have access to that
molecule in the tiny bit of color space
that hubble has access to now we're
opening that up and we'll see all of
these carbon species like methane and
carbon dioxide in addition to the water
and that's going to allow us to verify
our models and to understand the climate
of all of these exotic worlds and and
and in doing so it's like you you make
them a real destination now they start
to have a personality they don't just
have a mass or a radius now they've got
a climate
they have a temperature structure they
have color
so it really makes these planets look
like an actual destination yeah but you
still need to tell me your favorite
molecule that you want to find
we're going to be measuring
no no no no
stop stop i'm talking about a planet
that could have life
give me a molecule
that somebody's exhaling what molecule
are you looking for
webb was not designed to be a life
finder
it's not
it will be able to affect the atmosphere
of a terrestrial-sized planet but it's
not sensitive enough to detect oxygen
unless
we spend it the entire ten years
observing only that planet okay
yeah going to do that
sacrifice of all this other assignments
that we need to know of course of course
of course okay i'm always here well
the web is not a life finder however
i
going back to these this mysterious
class of planets we're going to measure
the ratio of carbon dioxide to methane
for example these two molecules that
sounds super boring except it's going to
tell us
what these planets are are they more
like a neptune that is like a scaled
down version of neptune or are we
starting to see
the byproducts of geological activity
bubbling up and being released into the
atmosphere so that's to me is very
exciting because then that would
indicate more real estate for life in
the future and like you said it turns it
from just an object to a world that you
can imagine
things happening on its surface and that
that that's a game changer
not only for our imaginations but for
storytellers who might set
uh uh sci-fi
tales
in space
you've just answered a lot of questions
in that and that answer just there
because there's a lot of people who are
asking about life and so i'm gonna ask
nicholas godlov who is a is a science
student and is hoping to follow in your
footsteps as an exoplanet scientist grad
student asks about extrasolar objects
whether the jwt will help us find those
and uh
and said like uh
oh
because we can't leave out the
possibility of these things being alien
like a ship a beacon a waypoint or
debris etc but this is this is extra
solar that means something that's not
attached to a star right the extra solar
he means beyond the solar system which
my first oh okay like i mean sometimes
they're called not exoplanets but extra
solar planets but when he referenced
omua now i know exactly what he's
talking about omua mua is this
asteroid-like object
that we observed
far away i mean we saw it projected on
the sky and what scientists could
discern from the data is that was not an
object that was gravitationally bound to
the solar system it was an interloper it
came from interstellar space and it
passed by the solar system and went on
its way
um now there's some
questions that have been raised whether
or not that could be maybe not just an
asteroid maybe it was something
intentional
um
so there you start to talk about techno
signatures or you know even biosignature
signs of life science of intelligence um
so
as far as i'm aware
there have not yet been any selected
programs for the first year of web
observations to search specifically for
techno signatures however
keep in mind that every time web takes
data it goes to a public archive and
that data becomes
available to anyone all over the world
so anybody could go and use the archival
data after the fact to go back and
search for techno signatures on their
own so um i imagine that that would be
done i mean that should be done with
every piece of data that nasa takes
because all of it's in the public
archive and it all can be searched for
anomalies no anomaly detection
yeah i'm going to see alien tv shows
that's what i want to see see what they
yeah but it's all public and all the
people i've got two questions left
uh let's do this quickly one specific
and one's general uh paul love asks uh
does the new image of a moon forming
disc around the planet in the pds-70
star system affect theories of how our
moon formed or has that type of scenario
already been rolled out for how our moon
might have formed
that's a really complex and very
profound question
we don't fully understand all of the
details about our own moon's formation
but all of the evidence points to the
fact that it was a collision with a
mars-sized object that left as its
remnant a moon-sized object
the
object that he's referencing is a
system that has been observed through
direct imaging we see this disk
um
i'm if i had to posit a guess i don't
know the answer to your question but if
i had to posit a guess i would say that
the formation mechanism is very
different for that system because the
planet in question is a giant planet
we're talking about very large planets
so the way that jupiter saturn uranus
and neptune formed their moons is very
different than the way the earth formed
its moon and you you have the first clue
that that's true when you look at the
mass like the mass ratio of the
satellite to the planet
for the earth moon system we've got this
gigantic moon for earth size
so that just speaks to a completely
different formation mechanism right at
the start and that's different from what
you're looking at with this other system
and just to be clear the moons there are
many moons of jupiter and saturn that
rival the size of our moon it's just
that jupiter and saturn are huge
compared to earth so this is this ratio
that natalie's trying to uh um hammer in
there about why that matters so thanks
for making that point definitely matt
one last question you had
i always like to finish on something
that's a bit more sort of profound a bit
more general um but zeki majed says how
will the james webb telescope further
shape this generation's vision of the
world as hubble had done before it for
the previous generation
i like that
oh gosh i'm not a fortune teller
but um well comment how about this
natalie comment on the pr problem that
you cited we got to love hubble because
of the beautiful color pictures it's
sent back to us if most of what you're
doing is spectra making
is in the analysis of rainbows
then people will rely on the science you
say comes from it rather than from their
desktop picture that they put from the
telescope itself well just quickly um
web will take beautiful images as well
it has cameras on board that are taking
images so you will see some um fantastic
new vistas
but i think the transformational science
is in the what we call spectroscopy
neil will let me say that word other
news outlets have
have told me not to say that word
well you already said rainbow you
already said rainbow so
we'll kick it up a notch since we
we got the rainbow out
on you
so spectroscopy is the study of rainbows
and we the the rainbow of light carries
so much information with it that's how
we learn about the universe and so one
thing webb could do is to really see
this notion into the public
consciousness about how we utilize
rainbows to learn about the universe
that already
would be a tremendous leap forward for
our collective consciousness
but in addition to that we're going to
learn so much about all of these
different objects and
really what i'd like to say is webb
might not be designed for life as a life
detector but it is one way station on
the way there and the decadal survey
already put forward the plan for the
next flagship mission beyond webb which
will be that life finder and it's going
to make use of all of the physics that
we learned about how planets form evolve
and and what makes a planet potentially
habitable and where the most likely
abodes of life are going to be so that
we are well positioned to use that
telescope that comes later and you will
be alive if you are in high school today
you will be alive when that first
discovery of a living world hits the
headlines
natalie let me let me set you up for
another
a hole in one here uh if a hubble part
of why an entire generation embraced it
is because it was taking data for their
entire time they were in school hubble's
sort of useful life
generating images is 20 30 years people
elementary school middle school high
school college hubble was there for them
what is the usable lifespan
of
jwst
and when it runs out of station keeping
fuel or whatever it is
is that enough into the future so that
at this l2 point since you said earlier
that could be a place where other
telescopes hang out
might it be a place that astronauts
visit to maybe refuel it and keep it
going
such good questions okay first of all
humans what we fall in love by like what
the fifth date
that's pretty quick right i made that up
that statistic
okay but we fall in love pretty quickly
and and webb will give us um five to ten
years so it's baselined for five years
but it has enough consumables on board
to last for ten that is significantly
different than hubble and it's out at l2
where it's not serviceable yet or now
um the plan i hope i think i've seen a
little bit of is to create a cis lunar
station and from a cis lunar station
it's like a
like the international space station but
it's out closer to the orbit of the moon
and when you get out at those distances
you don't need a very big velocity kick
you know slingshot velocity rocket
velocity kick to get out to l2 it's
easier so if we can do that we should be
able to
build telescopes at l2 service
telescopes at l2 send astronauts out
there and back keep in mind that the l2
is four times further away than the moon
is so it's it's a million miles away
it's quite a long distance but even
though that sounds really far and
difficult a cis lunar station would help
to make that a reality and i do think
that's part of the long-term plan not
within the next 10 years though so once
the astronauts do get out there to l2 or
their robots
it would probably be archaeological not
um active
[Laughter]
archaeological
wow
i like that so so the future frontier
science
i one day will be archaeological for a
next generation that's
that's simultaneously beautiful and
disturbing
[Laughter]
natalie it's
a delight to have you on this program uh
maybe when first light happens with the
telescope we can get you back on and you
can give us an update on how the science
is unfolding uh after of course the
engineering marvel the unfurling of the
of this uh of the telescope as it
happens perfectly uh
and matt you're you'll come back for
that right we'll
we gotta we gotta i will be there i'm
gonna be able to bring the band back
together for this
[Laughter]
we can yeah it to my results where i'm
just going to be tying an iphone 3 to a
helium balloon and uh we'll see who gets
the better pictures that sounds perfect
all right fingers crossed everything
goes well
thank you so much for having me
excellent and and natalie where do we
find you on social media
uh and battalia on twitter and facebook
and and matt where do we find you
uh matt kirschen on twitter matt
underscore cursion on instagram but i'm
really there twitter's where i mostly am
so mackerson on twitter and facebook and
the name of your podcast mostly science
it is probably science
all right this has been star talk the
james webb space telescope edition i'm
neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
keep looking up
[Music]